hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
days God is one of the most anticipated
games seen at e3 it's now been a full
year since the initial reveal and we
have seen some behind closed doors demos
and now we can give you more details in
fact there are 9 things you should know
about this gun the story is quite
run-of-the-mill
it's a post-apocalyptic zombie escapade
which are very popular in this day and
age that's two years after one of those
worldwide pandemics which has pulse
humanity into disarray the infection
turns adults into free-cos and children
into those little golem nest creatures
known as mute animals will also fall
victim to this disease but we'll get to
that in a moment at this point in time
the remaining members of the human race
have become killing machines and of
siphoned into factions kind of like The
Walking Dead from season 3 onwards all
like the Last of Us in terms of somber
survival and storytelling you play as a
bounty hunting biker named Deacon Saints
jóska he's lost everything at this point
and therefore he has a steely
determination and a lack of care all at
the same time the perfect protagonist
this isn't confirmed but he's wearing
biker leathers which could represent his
part in a biker gang like in Sons of
Anarchy which you should definitely go
and watch by the way if you haven't
already if details matter to you then we
can tell from his cut that he's part of
the mongrel biker club by the logo on
his back he's a road captain which means
his knowledge of travel and route
binding is unmatched he has a normal
patch - inferring that he isn't confined
to one area or one chapter of the club
in one shot we've seen the road captain
patch but look in the latest shot if
there's enforcer if you're an enforcer
in a biker gang you're usually pretty
hard and quite good at shooting things -
not that I would know let's talk about
the wildlife in days gone so far we are
seeing wolves bears and crows all of
which are susceptible to the outbreak
and are extreme
little each one of them has attributes
you should be aware of when playing for
example the wolf can outrun you even on
your motorcycle so fending them off is
imperative when being chief just make
sure you're aware of your surroundings
the crows appear when the weather
changes and the bear well we haven't
seen the bear in action yet but my word
that looks like an epic boss fight what
other animals do you want to see in the
game fingers crossed for an accepted to
rap Deacon is a biker his vehicle is
extremely important to him he set it up
for all-terrain you so don't feel
compelled to stick to the roads and
trails it's not here solely to get you
from A to B either it has a key
importance on your journey think of it
like a mobile inventory or a
transportable treasure chest deacon
can't carry everything he finds so his
bike offers respite for all scavengers
who can't leave anything behind
speaking of rummaging through every nook
and cranny the crafting system requires
use of everyday items from before the
apocalypse the oil filter found in an
old vehicle can be used as a gun
suppressor the airbags for improvised
explosives and even three black has a
use for deacon he can even put bear
traps to good use - I don't want to draw
too many parallels to the last of those
but the scavenging and the item creation
definitely shares some similarities
let's talk about the weather this is one
which I didn't really expect to change
the game drastically but it really does
dictate how you need to play the enemies
you encounter and how you overcome
obstacles differ when the weather
changes for example the freaker's are
not fans of the snow so if you venture
out at that time of the year
expect to see less of those freaky
buggers running around similarly with
the wool during the 2017 III demo we saw
wolves eating a body on the roadside
well if this section was played in
winter then you'd likely see crows
consuming that body instead the weather
is truly dynamic and the day/night cycle
keeps things interesting
- what's pretty cool though is that when
your visibility is impaired
then expect the enemies to have the same
issue to which you can use your
advantage
even the bikes traction and speed will
take a hit in different weather
conditions the developers say that your
ability to improvise in the game is a
key part of how you play think of it
like environmental management that's
somewhat something a teacher would say
them let me explain
take the chase thing we saw last year d
can have the ability to change the path
of the free Cahors blocking routes to
give himself time to escape or on the
flip side of that the environment offer
opportunities to mislead and misdirect
enemies and you can even occupy them
with a swarm of the undead if your
tactics are right
and of course those environmental kills
are here as gruesome as you can imagine
this all plays into strategy will you
plan or will you run and gun the choice
completely oz Sony bender at the helm of
this project and if you don't know them
don't worry they do have pedigree they
are responsible for the brilliant size
and social series and more recently than
that
uncharted golden Abyss on the Vita which
sadly was not playing are to many people
but it was an excellent vision I thought
that end by trying to compare the games
with others in terms of genre and
setting and crafting to this have
elements of the Last of Us the stealthy
nature of the open-world feels a lot
like horizon zero dawn under set faeces
draw from the Uncharted series just kind
of going away and you are I don't think
I could give this higher praise at this
point even at this early stage the
developers have stated they have had
three hundred plus breakers on screen at
once and over one thousand in a single
encounter I have high hopes the days
gone but what do you think up for
another zombie Phil's open-world
adventure because I know I am I'm Adam
from PlayStation grenade but more on
days gone please subscribe and join our
dysfunctional family it has been a
pleasure I'll see you next time